[Music]
speaking of things that are important in
life i would love to ask you about this
and this is going to be a interesting
transition the the sacred and then the
secular and for the secular i have a
very specific kind of technical question
but on the sacred i'd love to ask you
what role religion plays
in your life
if any how do you think about that
it's actually i think playing in
increasing role in in recent years and
so i mean i was raised jewish
and i think for
i don't know i'd say
from the time i went to college or so
maybe i wasn't as focused on it but i
think a few things in the last five or
six years have made me
a little more focused on it one is of
course family and having kids right so
you like wanna have traditions for
the kids
and
a lot of the time it's like okay well
here are the things that i did when i
was growing up
that i thought were meaningful and the
ones that are good do what you want you
want to do and the ones that that aren't
um
you don't but but i i i just found
having that
community and values grounding was was
really valuable so so we are raising our
our our girls to be jewish and that's
that's just become a more important part
of our our lives so it's like every
friday pretty much no matter what's
going on we do shabbat dinner
you know priscilla actually loves this i
mean she's
basically it's sort of a meditative
thing for her but from i think about
tuesday or wednesday she starts carving
out like an hour or so of the day to
like start cooking the shabbat dinner
and basically we have a bunch of friends
over and like and it's it's just like a
real center point of the week
that element i think is more cultural
i'd say for for me personally and for a
company
probably for a lot of people around the
world i mean the last five or six years
have been pretty tough right it's i mean
if you just look at how people felt
about our company
you know before 2016
if you look at like average sentiment
around the company it's like there was
almost like never a month when the
sentiment was negative and since 2016
there's almost never been a month where
the net sentiment has been positive
there have been so many social issues
that have been kind of brought to the
forefront
that we talked about this a little bit
before in terms of the oversight board
and how it's important that it's not
just like
you know one person or one company
making all these decisions trying to
balance these complex social equities
but
now part of me is like
i've kind of
gotten an appreciation for why
there just need to be things that are
bigger than you in your life so
even though
our country has a lot of struggles i
probably
believe more in democracy now than i
would have i probably didn't think about
it that deeply before but i just think
like you know believing in in kind of
democracy in our institutions is like
sort of a bigger force than any
individual i think is sort of a
grounding thing
but i think similarly believing that
there are things that are bigger than
that like god is also just sort of a
really grounding thing for me the more
you sort of study
the bible or the torah or whatever
there's there is like just a lot of
wisdom in it in in terms of you know how
to
live your life how to think about
creation and building i mean no matter
what you're doing no matter how kind of
modern or technological it is
you know i just think that there are
interesting
lessons it's really kind of meaningful
to me it's like at the beginning of the
the torah in genesis most of like the
the bible is basically rules for how to
live your life and but it starts with is
like why does it start in this place of
of talking about the creation
and it's like it starts off with like
okay god created people in in god's
image and it's like well what does that
mean what does that mean you're supposed
to go do it starts off talking about
creation right it's like how god created
all the stuff it's like yeah i think
that there's like a real interpretation
in that that
is
kind of personal to me which is like a
lot of what we are here to do is create
good things in the world and i think
that's like very intrinsic to
you know it's like when i'm having a bad
day or a bad month i just think like
there's something that's sort of
grounded in
it's like no this is like what
i think a big part of what we're here to
do is like build things that make the
world better and i think that is like a
fundamental thing that is sort of
ancient wisdom as people face challenges
in their lives and
as you think about the next generation i
think that these are both
things that tend to ground you and
tie you to much longer arcs and
traditions and that's certainly been the
case in my life i've actually gone to a
number of shabbat dinners here in austin
with friends of mine and
it's it's made me feel like i have
perhaps a ritual deficiency
it's such an incredibly grounding
nourishing
tradition i mean outside of the
religious context
and it also what you're saying reminds
me i'm blanking on the book i think it's
four thousand weeks but that's by oliver
berkman and there's a chapter called
cosmic insignificance therapy just the
relief that one can feel
when their time horizon what they're
considering sort of spans outside of
themselves balance is to understand that
there are things that are bigger than
you but what you do still matters
you